i've got really bad news i'm sorry i
have to have to report this to you
as a result of the dobbs decision
hundreds of thousands of babies per year
will now be saved from being murdered
that's true and the people of the states
get to
choose their own abortion laws which is
something that's a right that they have
not had since
1973 but on the on the flip side of that
pokemony might leave the country
yes
the roe vs wade
news is
absolutely terrible
i tweeted about it i already a couple
things i faved a couple things it's just
tough because
[Music]
what more can we even say at this point
we've said it all
it's depressing
i booked a ticket back to canada like
anna
no pokemony
pokemony you're going back to canada no
how can you
first question just before we move on
who is pokemony i don't know i saw this
headline come up i had not heard of
pokemony i had heard of pokemon the the
japanese cartoon but i had not heard of
pokemony she is a twitch streamer
and not only is she a twitch streamer
she is not american
she is from my very modest googling
she is
moroccan
and canadian
but she's in america right now and she's
very upset by the dobbs decision to save
the babies and why is she upset she
can't quite articulate it she says what
is there to say for someone like
pokemony probably there's not quite a
lot to say and she says i'm i'm going
back to canada
okay
uh all right
i think that's fine why
why do i care what pokemon thinks i
certainly don't even further
why should i care
what a moroccan canadian thinks about
my laws why should i care about that and
why should i care that this
foreign twitch streamer is now going to
leave my country because she's so angry
that we're not going to kill quite so
many babies
why why should her opinion have any
effect on me whatsoever
it does not she has influenced some
people but not with me she's not the
only foreigner who's weighing in
on this issue
we've we've got uh mr macron emmanuel
macron the leader of france
who
is very upset about the supreme court's
decision in dobbs for some reason and he
tweeted out quote abortion is a
fundamental right for all women it must
be protected i wish to express my
solidarity with the women whose
liberties are being undermined by the
supreme court of the united states
now the irony there's there's so many
layers of irony to macron's statement
but the top line is
in france abortions are only allowed for
any reason up until 14 weeks
up until 14 weeks
the law in america the mississippi law
that brought the dobbs decision to
overrule roe v wade to let the states
make their own abortion laws
the mississippi law
bans abortions after 15 weeks
abortion is more restricted in france
than it is
in mississippi which is the center point
of this case and yet macron weighs in
goes this is terrible what you americans
are doing you are getting rid you are
making your your abortion laws almost as
restrictive as ours are this is a
fundamental right
abortion obviously is not a fundamental
right
but even if it were
america would be even in mississippi
would be protecting that right more than
more than macron is
denmark's prime minister metta
frederickson
says my heart weeps for the girl i'm not
going to do a danish impression i just
don't have
my danish accent is not quite so good
my heart weeps for the girls and women
of the u.s whenever i don't have an
accent i just do jordan peterson my
heart weeps for the girls and women of
the usa a huge setback the right to a
free abortion is one of the most
fundamental rights there is
well they're really escalating the
rhetoric it's not just abortion safe
legal and rare it's every abortion's a
tragedy but we have to permit it for
some reason then it became no abortions
a right now it's abortions
one of the most fundamental rights there
is
life is the most fundamental right there
is without the right to life no other
rights can possibly exist now the libs
are inverting that they're saying
the right quote-unquote to kill your own
child is one of the most fundamental
rights does that seem coherent to you
not to me she goes we must never
compromise
the unrestricted right of women to
decide over their own bodies and future
you know the irony here layers and
layers of irony you probably are
guessing it
in denmark
unrestricted abortion is only allowed up
to 12 weeks
the danish laws on abortion are much
more restrictive than the mississippi
law
it's so
ignorant it's they just don't
either they don't know
what our laws are the laws that they're
weighing in on and pontificating on
or
they just want to hold us to a different
standard than they're holding themselves
the one good thing here
outside of the ignorance and presumption
of of macron and this and frederickson
is
it shows you just how important the
dobbs decision is
because the dobbs decision doesn't just
affect america because america isn't
just a nation america is in fact an
empire
and everyone around if you've ever
traveled around the world especially
near an american election you will know
that
virtually every other country on earth
treats the american election as very
important to their own countries
treats the american election as though
they are part of an american empire
because in many ways they are and so
when america does something like this
when america radically changes course
and says you know we're not we're not
going to outlaw abortion unfortunately
just yet but we are going to
restrict abortion and allow the people
to make their own abortion restrictions
that has reverberations outside of just
the united states
that that has reverberations throughout
the world even just in the fact that
america in its foreign policy now will
be more reined in in promoting abortion
because there is no national right to an
abortion there is no constitutional
right there have been a number of
protests of the dobbs decisions
politicians screaming young women
protesting with babies and fake blood
and things like that
women in dallas took a different tack
they protested the dobbs decision
by by twerking
everywhere in public
[Applause]
a lot of twerking it seems to all be
women
who were generally sort of androgynous
people they're all twerking on each
other
[Applause]
my
my body my choice
and jiggling uh
there were various screams and cries of
the sort of you know [ __ ] walk chants
you forget about i don't want to be a
mother down with the patriarchy i'm a
i'm a proud [ __ ] and a hoe and all that
kind of stuff
my only take on these protests
the ladies if they want to twerk i
suppose they can twerk my only take on
the protests is if you are just a normal
person right and you don't pay a ton of
attention to politics and you you're not
a pro-life advocate
going out in the street praying rosaries
in front of planned parenthoods and
you're not a pro-choice activist a
pro-abortion activist who's going out
there and
and making your voice heard if you're
just a kind of ordinary person in the
middle who goes about your daily life
and goes to work and takes care of your
family and you see
this and you see that
is that going to convince you to join
their cause
i don't think so
i don't think it will
the women who are going out there and
jiggling and twerking and screaming
i think they misunderstand
what ordinary people want i don't think
that ordinary people want to be just
degenerate promiscuous
degenerates they're i guess it's a
little redundant but i don't think
that's what most people aspire to be
and even if the twerking in the protest
is ironic they seem to believe that the
conservatives are are trying to protect
babies just because we hate women or we
or we hate sexuality or we were really
if you look at
pro-life people
you'll notice they tend to have a lot of
kids
they're not they're not sex negative
okay they're pretty sex positive they
just realize that sex
is supposed to exist within certain
constraints the fact that sex is so very
important to our nature which the libs
have been telling us for so so long and
that's behind the transgender movement
that's behind the whole rainbow movement
they're saying sex is so important that
we've got to take it very seriously
that's what the pro-lifers are saying
they're saying yes sex is very very
important
and it's a very powerful force and it
can go off the rails like those ladies
in dallas are showing you and so we've
got to make sure it remains within
certain confines so that it can be
ordered in the right way and we can
channel that and don't end up like them
i hope these women keep twerking i think
every time one of these women jiggles we
get another pro-life activist every time
someone sees one of these people shaking
around we're going to get another
republican vote in november
if you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show make sure that you
check out the rest on apple podcast
spotify wherever you listen to podcasts
and most importantly of all
because we need your support become a
daily wire member go to dailywire.com
knowles access an entire library of
exclusive content and use code knowles
for 25
off your new membership today
dailywire.com
knowles code knowles what's my name
knowles see you next time
[Music]
[Music]